il faut aussi vite que j'ai pu
l'espoir est il encore permis mon père
malheureusement non comme vous le savez
il a survécu mais du coup qu'il a pris
sur la tête lui a fait perdre la raison
seniors centriste en nous sommes perdues
toutes nos dernières batailles ont été
gagnés grâce à ses prédictions lui il ya
deux ans ils nous empêcha tombés dans
l'embuscade des barbares en contournant
le fleuve il a un don il avait mon fils
parce que là vraiment est cuit attendait
qui nous dit qu'ils ne tentent pas
justement de communiquer avec nous et
bien le fait qu'il ne communique pas
avec nous regardez c'est le signe des
vieux pêcheur
cela veut peut-être dire qu'il faut
passer par les côtés oui je reconnais
bien là tristan alors moi j'aurais
plutôt compris qu'il a besoin d'un
bougeoir comme quoi c'est peut-être que
juste une question d'interprétation
monfils perd gaspard vous ne comprenez
pas il est en train de lire l'avenir
continuer tristan nous avons besoin de
vous et donc là ça veut dire quoi
une terrible maladie va décimer notre
peuple a avoué juste un taré un notre
civilisation va découvrir un nouveau
continent apparaît toujours
serait ce un nouveau moyen de se
défendre une nouvelle arme ou antar et
enfin je campe sur les positions
personnellement serait ce un royaume qui
ou l'apparition d'une activité populaire
un nouveau sport peut-être ça veut dire
tard et aux magnifiques comme j'avais
déjà dit trois fois pareil je tentais de
petites variantes
[Musique]
une sorte de joute qui opposerait les
paysans à
[Musique]
vous avez raison il est complètement
taré l'amour que je porte pour cet homme
aveuglé là est la vérité je ne peux voir
un homme de se rendre dans cet état plus
longtemps combien de temps lui
reste-t-il à bala si je le souhaite pas
il passe pas la nuit
faites donc merci très bien c'est
peut-être une danse en fait cette partie
bon jusque mais hélas ça veut dire quoi
l'apparition d'une chaîne youtube
peut-être moins six à multiprise il dit
qu'il faut absolument s'abonner sans
quoi la pour calypso nous guette
ouais ça me semble un peu tiré par les
cheveux mais bon dans le doute
abonnez-vous ça mange pas de pain là il
dit qu il dit qu' il faut que vous
veniez numéro de téléphone de votre
soeur celle qui est bonne hein très bien
c'est 06 12